-The grand jury
investigating Donald Trump's
hush money payment
to Stormy Daniels
heard from yet another
key witness yesterday,
in a sign that
the Manhattan district attorney
is bolstering his case
against Trump
ahead of
an expected indictment.
Trump, meanwhile, appeared on
Fox News to sweat and grimace
and be weird as usual,
and also to attack
his likely rival
for the GOP nomination,
Ron DeSantis.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel like a lot of us
are waiting
for some cinematic moment
when Donald Trump
gets arrested
while forgetting
that in real life,
nothing is that satisfying.
If Donald Trump was Jason,
not only would he not die
at the end of the movie,
he would be allowed
to hold public rallies
where he complains that campers
don't skinny dip
like they used to.
It just seems like
Trump's been doing
so many crimes for so long.
I bet if you zoomed in
on that infamous photo of him
coming down the escalator
the day he announced
his first candidacy,
you'd see he had shoplifted a
pair of earrings from Claire's.
[ Laughter ]
That's why when he was
at the podium,
you could hear
a store alarm going off.
[ Alarm blaring ]
So, it's another day, and we're
all still waiting to find out
if and when Trump
will be arrested.
The news has basically
just become
the NORAD Santa tracker,
except for Trump's indictment.
Just a little circle
in the middle,
middle of the Atlantic Ocean.
Meanwhile, the grand jury
weighing a possible
Trump indictment
is still doing its work.
Yesterday, they heard
from yet another key player
in the hush money scandal,
in a sign that the Manhattan DA
is bolstering his case
against Trump.
-A key player
in the Trump hush money probe
just met with
a Manhattan grand jury
investigating
the former president.
A source confirms to CNN
that former National Enquirer
publisher David Pecker
appeared before the panel
earlier this afternoon.
-Sources close to
the investigation tell CBS News
that David Pecker's
appearance today is a sign
District Attorney Alvin Bragg
might be finalizing a case
against former president
Donald Trump.
In 2016, it was Pecker
who encouraged efforts
by then candidate Trump
and Michael Cohen
to prevent damaging stories
about Trump
from being published.
-Yesterday's convening
of this two-month-long
grand jury probe
appeared to center around
hearing testimony
from David Pecker.
Pecker is a central figure
in this drama,
as you pointed out,
about those hush money payments
to adult film actress
Stormy Daniels.
In his role at the time
as publisher
of The National Enquirer
and a friend of
then candidate Donald Trump,
he helped broker
the original $130,000 payment.
-That's right.
The grand jury heard
from a key player
in Trump's corrupt scheme
to broker a secretive
hush money payment
to conceal an illicit affair
just weeks before
a presidential election
and then disguised
those payments by lying
about what they were for.
It's a damning development
in what is already
a serious case
that could very well result
in a historic, first-ever
indictment
of a former president.
But my main takeaway
is this --
I can't believe
this guy's last name is Pecker.
It's...
[ Laughter ]
...a story about Trump
having sex with a porn star,
and a key player's last name,
it's Pecker.
So I guess in this way,
the Trump case,
you know, it is cinematic,
but it's like a bad '80s comedy,
like "Bachelor Party"
or "Porky's."
"Hey, Pecker, you want to help
us out with little problem?"
[ Laughter ]
Who else has the grand jury
heard from?
Trump's bookkeeper,
Mike Schlong?
So, the grand jury heard
from another key witness,
although I use that term
very loosely,
given that at this point,
we are all key witnesses.
I mean, we've heard
from Michael Cohen,
we've heard
from Stormy Daniels.
We've even seen the actual
check that Trump wrote.
Only Trump is stupid enough
to pay hush money
to cover up an affair,
but sign his name to a check.
Just fill up an envelope
with unmarked bills
like a normal criminal,
you dingus.
This is like if Gwyneth Paltrow
showed up to her trial
wearing a shirt that said,
"I'm a really bad skier."
[ Laughter ]
And then on her way
to the witness stand,
she just plows into the bailiff.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, it should be noted,
paying hush money
is not itself a crime.
I mean, it's not, like, cool,
especially if you do it
two weeks
before a pivotal presidential
election that will determine
who gets to fill three seats
on the Supreme Court.
But it's not necessarily
against the law,
if you do it the right way.
The problem is Trump tried to
cover it up by lying about it.
And you don't need
to take my word for it.
Here once again is star witness
Rudy Giuliani --
And just in general, a star.
[ Laughter ]
He's just got that "it" factor,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
...explaining how the whole
scheme worked back in 2018.
-That money was not
campaign money.
Sorry, I'm giving you a fact now
that you don't know.
It's not campaign money.
No campaign finance violation.
'Cause they funneled it through
the law firm?
-Funneled through a law firm
and the president repaid it.
When I heard Cohen's
retainer of $35,000
when he was doing no work
for the president,
I said, well, that's
how he's repaying,
that's how he's repaying it,
with a little profit
and a little margin
for paying taxes, for Michael.
-Yeah, that's the crime.
[ Laughter ]
You can't funnel money from your
business to your personal fixer
to cover up an affair
with an adult film star
to help your presidential
campaign two weeks before
an election and then lie
about what the money was for
by saying it's just a retainer
for your attorney.
It's the same reason you'd get
in trouble with your spouse
if you put an event in your
Google Calendar called
"Meeting with 'Pecker'
for work stuff,
not a euphemism for sex."
-Although -- although,
there is another part
of that clip that I love,
where Rudy explains
why he's so confident
this is all aboveboard.
-Funneled through a law firm,
and the president repaid it.
-Oh, I didn't know -- He did?
-Yep.
-There's no campaign
finance law.
-Zero.
-So, the President --
-Just like every -- Sean --
-So, this decision
was made by...?
-Everybody -- Everybody was
nervous about this
from the very beginning.
I wasn't.
-If everyone around you
is nervous and you're not,
you're either a Navy SEAL
or you're a moron.
And that ain't no Navy SEAL.
Although he does --
you guys, he does dye his hair
with Thompson's WaterSeal,
so that...
[ Laughter ]
This whole thing
is a reminder --
When Rudy tells you
not to worry,
it's time to [bleep] panic.
If Rudy's...
[ Laughter ]
If Rudy is your lawyer
and he tells you
he's not nervous,
the SWAT team is en route.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at this man.
He looks like he just found out
he's on this show.
[ Laughter ]
[As Giuliani] Uh-oh!
[ Laughs ]
I'm over Seth Meyers' shoulder?
This can't be good.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] So, Rudy
basically confessed
the entire crime
on national television,
and there is an abundance
of hard evidence to back it up.
But Trump supporters
and right-wing media
want you to think
this was all just an innocent
little record-keeping mistake.
-They better not put
my president in prison.
He represents
74 million Americans.
And if he's the nominee,
you're putting 74 million votes
in prison.
And that's how I see it.
-Really?
-On a bookkeeping charge.
-First of all,
I love one of the co-hosts
just saying, "Really?"
Because that is
the appropriate reaction.
It's insane to say
you're putting
74 million votes in prison.
Although it's very funny
to imagine a Trump supporter
showing up
to a federal penitentiary
and saying,
"I'm here to see my vote.
It's in prison."
And he has to have
a teary-eyed conversation
through a glass partition
with a piece of paper.
"Don't worry about it.
I'm gonna get you out of here."
[ Laughter ]
-With Trump under
at least four different
criminal investigations
and after he tanked
three successive elections,
including last year's midterms,
there's been a question as to
whether right-wing media
would finally pivot
away from him
and embrace Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis.
It started to seem like
maybe that would happen
when Fox started
airing glowing profiles
of DeSantis
and fawning interviews with him,
including one interview
where Fox host Brian Kilmeade
literally had a catch with
DeSantis on a baseball field.
Now, I could say they look
like a couple of dorks,
and I'd be right,
but in fairness, it's hard
not to look like a dork playing
baseball past a certain age.
I mean, Barack Obama
was our coolest president.
He made a three-pointer
on camera.
He wears sunglasses
and an open collar.
He hangs out
with Bruce Springsteen.
And yet even he looked
like a dork
when he was throwing
a baseball.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, if baseball
could do that to Barack Obama,
Ron DeSantis,
he never had a chance.
So, after that interview
with DeSantis,
there was speculation
that Fox might turn on Trump.
Some of Trump's goons
have also been exiled
to smaller right-wing networks,
like, you know,
the aforementioned Rudy,
who, as we just told you,
went on Fox a few years ago
and confessed to everything.
It seems like Rudy's been
unofficially banned from Fox.
So now when he wants to comment
on the hush money case,
he has to go on lesser-known
right-wing outlets,
where things just seem
to go horribly wrong.
Like this interview
from last week
where the host
began praising him
and then Rudy had some very
embarrassing technical problems.
-Mayor Rudy Giuliani,
always amazing to see you.
Love you.
Sorry.
I'm -- I'm just
so honored always,
as always,
to interview you, sir.
[ Laughter ]
Mayor Giuliani, what would --
what would you have done
if this case was
brought before you?
You prosecuted a lot of cases.
Before you became
New York City mayor,
you were a, you know,
a prosecutor.
What would you have done
if somebody said,
"Here's the case,
prosecute this"?
-Well, here's
what I would have done.
I would have told them
to go to hell.
[ Audio cuts out ]
I had it happen...
[ Laughter ]
-It looks like we're having
some audio issues there.
-We go way back to 19...
19...
-Oh, my God.
Maybe Rudy's lawyer told him,
"Instead of talking,
just pretend like
you're talking, and be quiet."
[As Giuliani]
Oh, that sounds...
[ Mouthing words ]
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, what happened there?
Did they turn off the Wi-Fi
at Rudy's nursing home?
This is like watching
one of those live webcams
from the San Diego Zoo
where the monkeys
start humping the camera.
Although, I have to say,
I think the hand over the camera
is actually an improvement
over seeing Rudy's face.
Just draw some eyes
and a mouth over it.
There you go.
Problem solved.
Also, I love that when
[bleep] starts going sideways,
not only doesn't Rudy
stop the interview,
they don't stop it either.
It's like they're
slowly realizing,
"Yeah, we should have known
it would go this way."
[ Laughter ]
So that's basically where Trump
and his inner circle are at.
And yet last night, Fox host
Sean Hannity chose to give Trump
a platform to ramble about
his usual bull[bleep]
without any pushback at all.
For example, last week,
Trump tried to menace
investigators into backing down
when he threatened death and
destruction if he's arrested.
But last night,
he claimed ludicrously
that he wasn't threatening
death and destruction --
he was just saying
he was scared of it.
-I will say this
with death and destruction --
I didn't say
death and destruction.
I said I'm afraid.
-The possibility. Yeah.
-I said I'm afraid
that if they do this,
which is a fake prosecution...
I didn't say,
"Do something bad."
I say I am afraid
that people will do something
because people are
very angry about it.
-Yeah, he didn't say,
"I'm gonna burn down
your restaurant."
He said, "It would be a shame
if something were to happen
to your nice restaurant
in the middle of the night,
say, 2 a.m. or so.
Capisce?"
[ Laughter ]
But my favorite part
of that interview
came when Trump totally
went off on DeSantis
and told an elaborate fantasy
about DeSantis begging him
for his endorsement for governor
back in 2018.
-So, what happened with Ron
is the following.
He came to see me.
He was getting killed.
He was being crushed.
Ron came to see me,
tears in his eyes.
He said, "I need you
to do me a big favor."
First he asked for the meeting.
Then he asked me for the favor.
I said, "What's the favor?"
"Would you endorse me?"
So I said,
"Let's give it a shot, Ron."
Okay?
And he was desperate.
I said, "Okay."
I gave him a nice endorsement.
I said, "You write out what
you'd like and let me see it."
He wrote it out.
I thought it was terrible.
I changed it, made it great.
I gave him a great endorsement.
From the moment
I pressed that button,
he blew the guy away.
The race was over.
-Personally, I'm just so glad
"tears in his eyes" is back.
I hope he keeps
adding to the story.
[As Trump] I was in
the Oval Office one day
and a guy came up to me --
little guy, tiny guy,
tears in his eyes, running...
The tears were running down
his face and onto the floor,
where they made puddles around
his fancy, little white boots.
Little white boots.
Splish-splash.
His little boots
were going splish-splash
in the tears he had cried.
Just tiny little
splish-splash-splish.
And he walked over to my desk
and you heard the little splish
and the splash.
And he said to me,
he said, "Sir,
I'm crying because I'm begging
for your endorsement
and also because I have
a tiny little...
-Pecker.
[ Laughter ]
-[Normal voice] This...
has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪